[Music]
hi everyone
my name is timon smachtawa and i'm the
lead game designer
of dying light 2. welcome to our ama
first of all i would like to thank all
of you for all of the
questions you have sent us it was more
than 9000 questions
so it's a lot we have chosen the one
that were appearing most frequently
[Music]
so first the number one question how big
is the map of dying light 2 so this is
something we have said before it's about
double the size of all of the maps from
dying light one combined if you have
played the first game i think it will be
easy for you to imagine how big
the map will be you will you just take
the slums you take the old town
you combine them and you double the
number and that's roughly the size of
the game space in dying light 2. if you
want to know the number
it's more than 6 square kilometers big
almost 7 square kilometers
but that's a simple answer which doesn't
take into account the verticality of the
world
so just imagine there are hundreds of
buildings and each one of them has at
least a couple of floors
there are even skyscrapers there are
roofs bridges
all of that stuff so you can imagine how
big the actual
space you'll be playing in is
oh that's a good one what is that zombie
with branches on its back
volatiles already gave me mini heart
attacks i'm worried i'll lose my life
now
i'm worried as well because the
volatiles in dying light 2
are even more scary so the fingers
crossed for you
and answering your question the guy with
the branches he's actually
a new type of infected in our game and
uh i don't want to spoil too much
because we are preparing a huge
drop of information about our infected
that's coming
but what i can tell you right now is
that he is definitely not
a nice guy and he will also give you
quite a lot of those
mini heart attacks the interesting thing
about this guy
is that you can actually make him happen
make him appear in your game so the fact
that he appears
in your world is just one of the
consequences that you can
have when you make specific decisions
so if he really is that scary for you
just try to make good decisions
and maybe he will not haunt your dreams
is this just going to be zombies at
night or will we see some wandering
around on rooftops
that's a very good question because it
touches on the most important rule
of the world of dying light 2 which is
the days for humans
but the night and the night is for the
infected what that means is that during
the day the infected hide inside
buildings
inside dark places where they can avoid
sun rays or uv lights
so yes there are less of them on the
streets during the day
but it doesn't mean you won't encounter
them there are still some
some some of them are weakened some of
them are slower but they still
pose a threat another threat that you
have to face during the day is of course
bandaids and other humans but that's
a different type of story another story
one more thing that you can do is you
can actually draw the infected from
their hiding places for example if you
make a lot of noise so then they run
away run from run from their hiding
places
and they try to attack you they try to
fight with you or
some other npcs some other humans around
of course it lasts only for a short
amount of time because they're afraid of
of the sun rays so then they go back
go back but yes you will still be able
to encounter them
during the day another interesting thing
you asked about is the rooftops
and it's interesting because it touches
on the another very important concept of
dying light too which is that
the rooftops are being used but by the
people that live in the city to rebuild
the civilization
so while you will be exploring actually
you will see a lot of
safe houses
farm fields and additional stuff like
that
on the rooftops so they need to be safe
so
there aren't that many biters virals or
other infected
on the rooftops during the day but of
course when the night comes it's a
completely different type of story
because the day is for humans but the
night is for the infected
okay but what about the guns yes
guns another question that came up very
often so this is something we have also
been telling you guys already so uh
there are no firearms in the world of
dying light too
why because it's a world where the
civilization is destroyed
it's gone so actually no one is able to
create
like professional firearms there will be
ranged weapons
bows and something extra which which fit
more the modern type ages idea the
modern dark ages concept
having said that there's actually one
option you can
choose to use something similar to a
firearm and this is a handmade shotgun
a very nice tool we have introduced for
you to create craft
with the stuff you have you you can find
during exploration
when you craft it when you create it you
can start using it using your left hand
so you can have a shotgun in your left
hand and a machete or a sword or a
hammer in your second one
and it really allows you to combine
those two tools in combat encounters a
very powerful combination
but the thing is that the shotgun
because it's handmade
it doesn't last long so it can get
destroyed very easily
so it's up to you when you decide to use
that powerful piece of weapon
[Music]
okay so uh is the grappling hook still
in the game
or as it was in the extended gameplay
trailer
if yes how does it work so of course it
is still in the game
and we have really put a lot of effort
into making
it a completely new tool
a tool that's better than the one that
you
got used to in dire glade one so i think
the most important thing for us was to
make the grappling hook as
real as natural as physical as possible
so um it works differently now you will
not be able to fly through the whole map
in one minute
as in the first game as i said it's way
way more
physical and way way more realistic so
if you need something to to to help you
imagine this is that
in the first game with the grappling
hook you could almost feel like
a spiderman in this game in the second
game you feel more like a tarzan
so swinging on ropes and and
everything so of course you could say i
prefer to be a spiderman and a thousand
good for you but wait till you see the
thing in action
it's really really really immersive and
it has a lot of uses not only in
traversal not only
parkour but also in combat so trust us
we know what you what we're doing
and you will enjoy the new grappling
hook a lot
oh this one is very important and very
interesting
the question is will there be cars
vehicles
in the main game area so the answer is
you will be driving inside a vehicle in
one specific mission the one we have
shown to you
at in our last demo we didn't want to
spend more time on it because we feel
all of our other traversal methods are
way way more interesting so of course
you have parkour
uh and with our natural movement system
and the improvements we have made
in the second game you can really travel
through the city
with great ease overcoming any obstacles
doing those huge jumps so it's really
really very exciting
and on top of that we also add the
grafting hook the paraglider
and some additional stuff we'll be
talking about in the future
so we wanted to stick to that because
this is the dna of dying light this is
what makes our game
[Music]
unique
okay so this one is actually another
question that appeared very very
frequently so the question is
how many choices do you have that
actually changed the world
and the story so i don't want to give
you an exact number but i want to
explain to you
how the whole system works so in dying
light 2 you make
choices you make decisions on three
different levels
so the first one the as you can see the
the upper one the top one
is a number of main story choices
a few of them which really change how
the story flows and
what kind of ending you will get when
you finish
the whole experience then the second
level is
choices and decisions you make inside
side quests or even
main quests that mostly have
consequences that are contained
within those quests within those
missions
or quite often they also influence the
world an example of this is
in one of the quests you can for example
save an opera singer
if you do that if you make a correct
choice then she
appears in one of the hubs in one of the
safe zones in the game
and starts singing some people like it
some people don't some people will tell
you
it was a stupid thing to do but it's all
up to you and this is an example of one
of those
little details that you can actually
change in your world
and the third level is the so-called
city alignment system
and this is a system where based on your
choices one of the factions takes
control over specific
areas of the city so when they do that
of course they
install their forces they install a lot
of
different things that belong to that
function and some of the things are the
things that you can use in gameplay
so for example if you play with the
peacekeepers they start
installing so called combat helpers
combat traps that you can use while
fighting with band-aids or infected or
whatever
if you side with survivors and you give
parts of the city to survivors
they'll start installing things like zip
lines and
trampolines and other stuff that makes
the traversal easier
so depending on your choices you can
also shape the gameplay space the
gameplay environment
and have a different experience
depending on what you do
[Music]
the next one is how diverse are regions
in dying light too
will we see fields and planes suburbs or
any additional locations so as you know
the game takes place inside the city and
it's a huge city so as all of
the huge cities out there in the world
is actually quite diverse
you can say that there are two main
regions
in the city which is an area which is a
little bit close to old town
and another one which is more like a
downtown with
huge skyscrapers and all of that stuff
within those regions there are seven
zones where you can make decisions
and assign those zones to different
factions so for example if you side with
survivors you will start seeing things
like
fields or bakeries or
other small communities that are
building rebuilding themselves around
various city locations
and if you side with peacekeepers you
will start seeing more of our military
stuff like
outposts barricades things like that
so depending on your choices and how you
assign each of the zones
you can end up with a completely
different looking type of city